- Try to have your own sound.
Try to invent, you know,
dig into yourself.
Music only became interesting
when people stepped over boundaries.
You don't want to be stuck
in just doing one thing.
As an artist you've got to develop.
As I notice, if I don't enjoy myself,
the crowd's more flat as well.
And I want to stress that the word passion
is probably the the
most important in life.
The past is who you are,
but you cannot change the past.
- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the worlds major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from legendary Dutch DJ,
Armin van Buuren,
and my take on his top
10 rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys liked the best.
And as always,
as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired;
you might win a prize as well.
And also, when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(jet engine)
(upbeat music)
- Look at other DJs, see
why their sets are good,
but try to have your own sound.
Try to invent, you know.
Dig into yourself,
and see who you are.
And kind of bring
something new to the table.
Because if you're just copying other DJs,
then you'll just be a copy.
So you've got to find your own identity
before you go out there.
If you do what other
people are doing out there,
then you're not going to stand out.
I always say deadmau5 is an example.
Hate him or love him.
But what he's done,
is you can put your finger on it.
You know, putting on a weird mouse head,
making excellent music,
that makes a difference,
that makes you stand out.
And,
I think the most important thing,
is if you want to be successful,
that you do whatever you love,
and you look at other artists.
Of course you look at other artists.
I do that as well.
You get inspired by other people's music.
But try to make it your own.
I mean, think of all these
people sitting at home,
and you're doing a concert in their city.
Ask yourself, why would these people,
when they're at home--
You know they're
comfortable, they're warm,
they're having a pizza,
they're watching TV.
Why would they come out to see you?
You know, answer that
question in two sentences,
and that's your answer right there.
I mean why would you go see deadmau5?
Because he's a brilliant producer,
a brilliant DJ, and he
puts on a weird mouse head,
and everybody goes crazy.
You know.
So, that tells you the whole story.
And I think that's what you have to do.
Look for--
Look inside yourself.
Who do I want to be?
What do I want to represent?
And what is my sound?
And of course we all look at other DJs,
but if you want to add something,
don't copy what's already out there,
but try to make things--
Make your sound current,
but make it your own.
Sometimes an instrumental
tune can get in the charts,
but it won't get as high.
Like Foo Focus was obviously
the first single from Mirage.
I consciously made the choice
to make an instrumental track
as the first single.
That wasn't a commercial choice,
I just wanted to show
the people hey, you know,
this is what rocks the dance floor,
and I know where I come from.
But I think all music grows
if you try to step over
your boundaries, you know.
If you look at the history of music,
whether it's Bach or Beethoven,
or the Beatles and Bob Dylan.
Or Pink Floyd.
They all looked at each other,
and music only became interesting
when people stepped over boundaries.
You see the same thing
happening now with David Guetta
and all kinds of hip-hop
artists teaming up.
I think it's only interesting for music.
So I made the conscious choice
to make half the album of Mirage
instrumental trance tunes;
that's where I come
from, that's what I DJ,
that's the sound that people know me for.
That's what I like,
tracks like Orbion, Coming Home, Mirage,
and all that sort of stuff.
And then the other tracks
are just a little bit
experimentation, you know.
I like all kinds of music.
I like the more housy stuff.
I like the more techy stuff.
I like a good song.
So for me Mirage is
also a little bit of a--
Ya, a little bit of a tryout
to see if people like this
new direction that I'm taking.
I think I'm the first DJ
that ever did a tryout show
like what they do in theaters.
But it was incredibly inspiring
to work with such a big group of people,
travel around the world, you know.
Normally I would just show
up with a bag of records,
and maybe my tour manager and a light guy.
And now we travel the world
with a group of 35 people.
And even though financially
it was the worst year I've ever had,
it was creatively, it was
such an inspiring thing.
Because I learned so much.
Actually my current DJ sets we
still use a time code system
that we designed for the Armin Only show.
So, you know,
I learned so much that my
performances got better,
thanks to that.
And it's just,
I think as an artist you
should show to the people
that you don't want to be
stuck just doing one thing.
As an artist you've got to develop,
you have to get in touch with new sounds,
try different things.
You know like on the Another You record
with Mr. Probz for example.
I hired an entire string orchestra.
If you listen to the track,
the strings that are
in the track are real.
So you can actually hear it,
because they're not exactly on time.
They're little bit off, but
that gives it the human feel.
So I was actually conducting an orchestra.
You know, din, din, din, din.
And it's great because I'm
not a conductor, I'm not.
I'm not a musician in that sense.
But it's great to learn.
I learned so much from that experience.
And I think you should show
that to your fans, you know.
I can't do the same thing twice,
even though I have a lot of
nostalgic feelings for the past.
I want to keep learning.
And this is something that
I've invested a lot of time in.
Musical--
I've been educating myself a lot.
On my iPad, following courses online,
and learning a lot of new
techniques, new plug-ins,
new sounds.
So you have to do that to
stay fresh and stay focused.
Recently I started touring
with this Armin Only concept,
which we brought to Madison
Square Garden in New York,
and the Forum in L.A., and
a couple of other venues.
It was really exciting to do
the idea behind the shows,
that I'm the only DJ, hence Armin Only.
But then we had the State of Trance,
which is basically my own festival.
It's a radio show, that I do live events.
The radio show is weekly,
but then once a year I
throw a massive event
with five areas.
That's all broadcasted live and for free.
So that's different.
I'm just trying to evolve.
You know, doing things that I like,
things that make me
exciting, keep me excited,
and you know, keep focused on the music.
(upbeat music)
It's all about, at the end of the day,
what do you want to deliver as an artist?
What do you want to bring,
what do you want to tell?
And it's so--
I mean the thrill that you get of an idea.
I mean I had the idea for
Ping Pong for example.
(upbeat music)
And I mean everything
in dance music right now
is so serious.
(upbeat music)
I wanted to add a little
bit of a fun element.
(upbeat music)
I mean, it's a little
bit of an ironic track.
(upbeat music)
I did it in four hours.
Ping Pong was just, oh you know, silly.
I didn't even want to
release it initially.
But it's so great that with all my tracks,
they're all my babies.
And you see a crowd going crazy to an idea
that you had in your head, and they go.
That gives the biggest kick.
Self-education is key.
Why not, instead of
watching another series
that everybody is talking about,
use that exact time and go online
and watch a couple of these tutorials?
Because that's what inspires me.
I learned a lot of tricks from producing,
making specific sounds.
You know, how can I make this pad,
and make it sound really wide?
How can I make this trance riff?
How do you program that?
How can I make my kick sound really phat?
How can I have that clap with
the big reverb behind it,
and reverse it?
And how do you do that?
How do I arrange my song?
Do I have enough elements
to arrange my song?
All these questions, and a million more.
You find answers online.
I promise you,
as soon as you finish a
couple of these courses,
you'll be so inspired,
and the music will start writing itself.
(upbeat music)
Well before we start doing this,
we had a massive rehearsal time,
and we hired the (mumbles)
in the Netherlands.
We flew all the artists
to the Netherlands.
And for three weeks we rehearsed.
So every single track was
rehearsed with staging.
We had the entire stage
there, and no crowd.
And then we did tryout shows.
We had two tryouts in
front of a live audience.
And then you immediately
see where the problems are.
So then we again, we rehearsed
and rehearsed, and rehearsed.
To get it better and better, and better.
And then we did the premier show
at the Ziggo Dome in Amsterdam.
We did the show for the very first time.
And you see that the show gets
better every time we do it.
Also my freestyles change every time.
So it's exciting for the crew,
because they don't hear
the same music every show.
So every Armin Only show
that I do is different.
The track list from the
show I did in Oakland,
was different than the track list
from the show I did in L.A.
So it makes it exciting for everybody.
And the crew feels really relaxed,
because they know exactly
what's going to happen.
So if I select a track
with a live element,
my stage manager backstage
sees it on his iPad,
he sees what tracks I select.
And then the next artist will be ready.
And the artist knows,
okay whatever track he has running before,
he knows that he or she
needs to walk on stage
at one minute 40.
So everybody's prepared.
And preparation is key.
And that's what I learned
from working with a theater director.
You know, so instead
of the awkward feeling
like sort of pushing a
microphone in a mixer
and say hey, okay sing.
Go, sing.
Instead of doing that,
we make sure that the
artist gets vocal coaching,
an artist is relaxed, an
artist gets treated well.
Gets a good hotel room.
Pick-ups, everything is
organized and arranged.
But it's a big operation.
I don't feel God is a DJ.
I don't like that expression.
I feel I'm really part
of the crowd in a way.
I try to enjoy the music
as much as possible.
Because I notice that
if I don't enjoy myself,
the crowd is more flat as well, you know.
People expect me to enjoy myself.
And I'm enjoying the music just as much,
or even more than the crowd,
because I'm really, really into it.
I feel that's my assignment.
And I want to stress that the word passion
is probably the most important
in that you have to really, really,
really want something.
And I think in life,
it's so much more easy if you are devoted
and dedicated to something.
If you like your job, no not
like your job, love your job,
you'll be 200% good at it.
Because you're passionate about it.
So ask yourself on a daily basis,
is what I'm doing right
now, is it something I love.
Because if you don't
love what you're doing,
you're actually wasting your time.
You should stop doing what you do.
You should try and search
for something else.
Because I'm convinced that if
you don't love what you do,
you're only doing at
maybe at 50
or 70% of what you could do.
And if you love what you do,
you're really passionate
about what you do,
you love you job or you love your work,
or you love whatever you're doing,
then you'll go for it 200%.
And then you'll see that
you can really excel.
You can reach stuff beyond
what you expected you would.
I mean, people always ask me like,
why do you do eight hour DJ sets?
It's because I love it man.
I want to play all this music.
And then, it physically,
it's not healthy to not go to the bathroom
for six, seven hours.
And I do it because
I just don't think about
going to the bathroom.
I just feel the need to perform.
Like, I'm in the zone.
I'm in the moment.
I want to rock that crowd.
And that's what I mean, you excel
You go beyond your--
A human being can really achieve--
It's like what Obi-Wan Kenobi said.
You know, "If you can put your mind to it,
you can accomplish anything."
But you have to understand for
me, when I'm in the studio,
I'm not thinking about
creating a hit record,
or creating a pop record
like you were saying.
- You're creating what you want to create.
- I'm just doing something
that comes from my heart.
- Okay.
- And sometimes it will please you,
and sometimes it won't.
- That's okay.
- So one day I'll produce
a track for the Gaya guys,
one day I'll make 1-3-8,
a Game of Thrones re-mix.
And then the next day I'll
be making a down tempo track.
It's good to have a plan.
It's good to have a clear
idea of where you want to go.
But along that--
If you take that path, and
along that road can be--
It can be bumpy.
And sometimes the road's blocked,
and you have to go somewhere else,
you have to take a detour.
I think it's really important
to look after your health.
Really, don't smoke.
Don't drink too much.
Take care of you own body, you know.
Your body is your temple.
It's the only thing that's
with you all the time.
So the past is who you are,
but you cannot change the past.
You know, in my job I'm always
looking for the next gig,
and the next album, and the next tour.
So I'm always living like
two, three months ahead.
But I want to be more in the now.
You know, when I'm with
my family on a holiday,
when we're having dinner,
when we're going to
the beach or something.
I wish I could just stop this head,
you know, stop the train,
and be in the now.
For me, I can say that trance
is emotional, uplifting,
mostly instrumental music
that just touches your soul a little bit.
It's very close to
classical music, you know.
It's about the melody more than the beat.
It's about the, yeah,
the flow that you get
into listening to it.
You just know.
You know when you're in love.
It's just very simple.
It's one of those strange
things in life, you know.
I mean, anybody that's
married can tell you this.
It's so easy to fall into the trap
of being roommates with
each other, you know.
So me and my wife, we go on dates.
We totally brought back date night.
(laughing)
Doing a big show,
especially when I did the Armin Only shows
from my last album Intense,
and now for the upcoming album
when I want to do a new
tour called Embrace.
It's so much energy that you see
when you see these people in front of you.
You get so much love from that crowd.
But you always have to
pay a price somewhere.
So the day after for
such a big performance,
I'm empty man.
When I get up in the
morning, the first thing,
that knock that goes through my head,
is not like oh how can
I make a million bucks.
Or how can I be number
one DJ in the world.
That's now what goes through my mind.
I get up thinking hey,
Mr. Probz is coming over,
and we're doing a track together.
How exciting.
And that's really what moves me.
The motivation is to
have fun in the studio.
And I understand that now.
It's so important to go into
the studio and have fun.
- I find it hard to believe
that you have the time to you know,
start working on an album,
start doing collaborations,
but also at the same time
how do you pick your collaborators?
It's sort of;
it just happens really.
You meet somebody, you say
hey let's do a track together.
You send each other a
text message, or an email.
And you're trying to find a date,
you sit in the studio together.
I mean, honestly,
half of the collaborations
that I tried to set up
didn't work out.
Simply because the artist didn't want to,
there was no time, or
had other priorities.
One of the collaborations I'm really proud
is actually not on Embrace.
It's with Jean-Michel Jarre,
the synthesizer legend.
For his album, he approached me,
and he said I want to do a track
with you for my next album.
(upbeat music)
I remember I was a little kid
going through my dad's record collection,
and seeing these humongous
covers of Jean-Michel Jarre.
So, you know the day
that I could tell my dad
that I was actually working
with the legend himself,
was unbelievable
So we created a track together
that I'm really proud of,
called Stardust.
Has more of my older trancing
melodies, my older sound.
And it was so much fun to do as well.
So this is what I want
to show you, you know.
In one year, working
with Jean-Michel Jarre,
working with Hardwell,
working with Mr. Probz,
working with a jazz trumpet.
I mean, that's fun.
I mean, you go into the
studio, and you're like wow.
It's not just another
singer, or another you know,
another celebrity who
wants to work with you.
No, it's about you go into the studio,
you try and do different things.
And you try different sounds,
and you go out of your
comfort zone a little bit,
and that challenges me.
I mean, I'm so inspired right now.
I could easily, if you put
me in a studio right now,
in a year from now I'll
have another album.
I have so many ideas,
and that's because I'm having so much fun
in the studio right now.
Last time I was here, I
told Ferry I had an idea
to use this drum kit,
because it sounds like a march, you know.
Like, you hear the army coming.
The big break is coming.
The war is about to start.
So you hear the army further away.
(intense music)
- This track is going
to be on the next album.
But like Armin said,
this is an addition to the actual track.
It's just a little break,
like a little teaser.
So it's not that you're
listening to a song
that's only doing this in the album.
(intense music)
- Loud. (laughing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
DJ Valence asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description,
and you can go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know
which clip resonated the most with you.
What lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Lucas Alexander.
Lucas, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting
that picture to Instagram.
I really appreciate the support man.
And I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(jet engine)
- We had 10,000 plus people
in, so you saw it yourself.
- Yes.
- It was crazy.
- And then also we had a vinyl set.
- A vinyl set, yeah.
- What's the idea behind the vinyl set?
- Well, I always see Armin Only
as Christmas dinner with
Armin van Buuren, so you know.
I also want to show my fans
that I'll never forget where I come from.
- Right.
- And instead of playing
re-works of the classics,
I was just like you know,
why not just play the original vinyl.
Which brings back the original
sound of the classics.
And I always felt that vinyl
added something special.
The sound of vinyl added something special
to the trance music.
Because actually,
you're getting less
information than from the CD,
or from USB key.
Because the sound characteristics of vinyl
they cut away the parts
of the frequency spectrum.
But it just adds something
to the sound, you know.
And yeah, it's a little
gift to my fans I guess.
(upbeat music)
Love it.
I mean, you know,
I've been DJ'ing for such
a long time in my career,
that you know, to keep it interesting
and exciting for myself,
I love doing various things.
So, what keeps me excited
for all these years,
is of course the music, the fans.
But also, you know doing
all these different shows,
and trying different things.
And I mean, a show like Armin Only
is not just the way to
promote the music or whatever,
but it's really also for
myself to keep it exciting.
And you know,
I want to wake up in the morning
thinking that wow, I'm going
to go to L.A. and do the show.
I'm going to bring this
person, and that person.
The secret to success.
There's a couple of elements
that are important in success.
First of all is your own
level of expectation.
You also have to learn to be happy
with what you achieve sometimes.
It's impossible in life to always achieve
exactly what you have in
the back of your head.
So you need to learn also to be happy
with what you achieved.
Even if it's only half of what
you had in mind, at first.
I like a quote of John Lennon,
"Life's what's happening to you
when you're busy making other plans."
And that is what I keep
telling my wife as well.
And a whole lot of people around me.
You always expect something,
and then something along the way comes,
and then you have to
alter your path again.
And if you can learn to live with that,
if you can be practical like that,
then success is more easy, maybe.
It's good to have a plan,
but it's also good if
you're working really hard
and you're walking up against a door
and you can't go through that door,
then you just find a backdoor.
It's find your way around it.
And that's just the way that life is.
Sometimes you cannot get
exactly what you want,
or what you had in the back of your mind.
Yes, it's very important
that you have to have a good work ethic.
Nobody gets anywhere without hard work.
And you'll have good and bad days.
Even myself as a producer,
I run into disappointments
almost on a daily basis.
Because I try to work with artists
that on the last moment
pull back their song.
You don't see that; you
don't read that in the news.
But it's a fact of the matter.
And I think all artists have
to deal with stuff like that.
You don't get the set times you want.
You don't get the billing you want.
You don't get the hotel
room that you requested.
It's something that you have to deal with.
And it, you know, defines your character,
how easy you are to deal
with stuff like that.
You know, life is a roller
coaster ride for everybody.
It has its ups and its downs.
But if everything goes well,
you'll have more ups than downs,
and you'll remember the ups
more than you'll remember the downs.
But it's a fact of the
matter that everybody,
no matter if you're a big
artist, a successful artist,
or a successful businessman,
everybody works hard to get somewhere.
It's not about, you know,
how many Grammy nominations you have,
or how many time you
won DJ Mag, or whatever.
It's not about that.
At that point you're just
trying to rock the crowd.
You're trying to interact with people,
and it's so beautiful.
I mean, to feel that
connection with a crowd,
seeing all those people having
the best time of their lives.
They're in an office during
the week, and they dress up,
and they go out,
and you get to be the guy
that gets to entertain them.
That is so beautiful.
I mean, from all the things
that I'm doing in my career.
Jet lag, airports, waiting, taxes,
everything.
From all the things
that I do in my career,
that is the only thing that
I'm still not bored with.
It's a thrill.
Why are the Rolling Stones still playing
when they're 70 years old?
It's because you can never
get enough of that kick,
of the love of the crowd.
It's an addiction, for sure.